let's jump back on the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 it's been a doozy of a phone
call day no no doubt about that
the phone lines are blowing up and we're
going to our next caller from the 805
area code caller from 805 say hello
who's this Tony Tony
now let me ask you this question Tony
we're not on speakerphone are we okay
bluetooth might be the only thing worse
than speaker go ahead tell you that you
agree with you that we have to focus on
the midterm yes because everything else
that everybody is talking about has
nothing nothing more forward right and
another thing that I wanted to point out
and talk to you about it basically the
role that the media I hear people
talking both things from both MSNBC and
Fox News that is just plain ridiculous
it's people the media is not keeping
their eye on the ball either I mean what
do you mean by that what's the media
missing Tony focus on 144 one too many
three days sometimes in they miss a big
chunk of other smaller things like so
for example the whole you know the
Republicans are trying to impeach judges
and where is the Pennsylvania yep
there's all that other stuff that the
GOP is doing that maybe the only reason
I bother people that I follow on Twitter
right but I don't have people talking
about all that they don't think it's
that bad and I think I hear it and when
I speak with people I go it's worse than
thing you think they're all well you
know maybe if the Democrats will get a
good candidate won't just vote for Trump
again you know it's I don't I think that
the information is not getting out there
and I mean I read a few of your your
previous collars and then you could
clean towel right there
I don't think we're focusing on what we
should we're just falling back to work
we're originally said it's focusing on
the midterm and 2020 all right Tony
thanks I appreciate you're absolutely
right i mean the the media gets focused
on one thing and sometimes it's it's
planned distractions I mean the memo
that the bogus memo we now know was a
great way to distract from the actual
Russia investigation and tons of other
stuff that was going on and we're doing
what we can to report it so I appreciate
the call Tony thanks very much